[संगीत]
हेलो एवरीवन
तो एक बार मुझे बता दीजिए की आप सबको मेरी
आवाज ए रही है नहीं ए रही
प्लीज एक बार कंफर्म कर दीजिए उसके बाद
स्टार्ट करेंगे
बताइए एक बार जल्दी से कंफर्म कीजिए
ओके थैंक यू
आयोग की आप लोगों ने हमारी जो लास्ट जो
हमारी डिस्कशन थी मेरी निर्देशक की आप
लोगों का भी कुछ पता चल गया होगा जो आपके
बेसिक डाउट रहते हैं करियर को लेकर साड़ी
चीजों को लेकर
और मुझे लगता है आप लोग काफी अपने दोस्त
लोगों में अपने बड़ी जिया जी जो लगता
स्टूडेंट है जिनको हमारी जरूर है उसमें
शेर किया होगा अगर नहीं किया हो तो प्लीज
शेर कर दीजिए क्योंकि रियली में वो जो
सीरियस प्रॉब्लम है वो सबको सब तक पहुंचनी
चाहिए जब मैं मानता हूं क्योंकि यह मेरी
पर्सनल प्रॉब्लम नहीं है सबके प्रॉब्लम है
और मैं वो मानता हूं की जो एक स्टूडेंट है
उसके पास वो वीडियो हनी चाहिए वह पहुंचने
चाहिए वह आगे कभी भी मतलब ना हो मिस गाइड
ना हो और उसे बहुत साड़ी चीज
मौका मिले और दूसरों से का दे गाइडेंस के
लिए ट्राई करें थोड़ा सा घर वालों से बात
करें मुझे बात करनी है समझना है
है तो
वही है तो एटलिस्ट के ट्री तू मैक्स शेर
आप अपने ग्रुप में अपने दोस्त को उसको
बोलिए की अगर आप भी अपने दोस्तों शेर
कीजिए जो हमारा विजन है जो हम अचीव करना
छह रहे हैं आप लोगों से आप लोगों के थ्रू
वो हम अपना विजन क्लियर कर पे अपना जो
टारगेट है वो अचीव कर पे टाइम चाहिए
तो एक बार फिर से मैं आपको हमेशा की तरह
याद दिल रहा हूं की ये हमारे युटुब चैनल
से है युटुब चैनल के अंदर जो लिंकडइन पेज
है उसे पे जाइए और जैसे ही यह देश है उनकी
क्लास और होती है वहां जान के बाद आपको
क्या करना है सिंपली वहां जाकर आपको यहां
पर पेज में एड हो जाएगा दे 7
क्लास और उसके अंदर आपकी कमेंट क्षेत्र
में जाइए और वहां पर यह कमेंट कीजिए की आज
की क्लास में आप लोगों ने क्या शिखा जो भी
टॉपिक आपने शिखा जो भी आप लोगों को समझ
में आया वो साड़ी चीज आप कमेंट करके हमें
बता दीजिए और थैंक यू
इतना प्यार दिया है लास्ट की कुछ क्लासेस
के जो कमेंट कर रहे हो आप लोग हमें सपोर्ट
कर रहे हो उसके लिए थैंक्स
मोटिवेट मिलता है जब आप लोग हमें ऐसी चीज
बताते हो मतलब ऐसी चीज कमेंट करते हो शेर
करते हो दूसरों को बताते हो और हमें अच्छा
लगता है और ऐसे अगर आगे शेर करते रहेंगे
लोग हमारे पास ज्यादा आएंगे और हम गो करते
तो हमारा भी ज्यादा मोटिवेशन रहेगी की हम
बटर से बटर मोस्ट अफॉर्डेबल कंटेंट आपके
सामने रख सकें मोस्ट अफॉर्डेबल और एक
क्लास को रेडी करने में हमारी बहुत मेहनत
लगती है जो हम कर रहे हैं वह हम करेंगे
क्योंकि हमने प्रॉमिस किया है हम अपने
प्रॉमिस पर हमेशा रहते हैं वह एक दिन
छोड़कर एक दिन हमने क्लास प्लेन की और
हमारी अभी तक ए रही है जब तक हमें कुछ
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है या टेक्निकल शो नहीं हुआ
तब तक हमारी क्लासेस जाएगी
वो कोई नहीं रॉक सकता
है वैसे आते इतने लोग हैं 10 से 12 लोग तो
यह मुझे बेसिकली सबसे पहले आपको बताना था
की यह हमारा लिंकडइन पेज वापस जाइए
की हम प्रैक्टिस कर सकें तो ठीक है आज नया
टॉपिक स्टार्ट करेंगे
तो ऐसा नहीं है की जी फोटो टाइमिंग
हम फ्यूचर को सोचते हुए सीरीज को निकाला
है क्योंकि मैक्सिमम लोगों को उसकी हेल्प
मिलनी चाहिए और इतना बेसिक तू कॉन्सेप्ट
हमें इसलिए उठाना पड़ता है
मुझे पता है की इसमें बहुत साड़ी ऐसे लोग
होंगे कुछ मेरी क्लास से रहे होंगे कुछ
ऐसे लोग इन्हें लिरिक्स आता है अब उन्हें
बर ग रहा होगा इसलिए वो क्लास लाइव क्लास
में आना पसंद नहीं करते मैं समझना हूं यार
दोबारा चीज देखना बहुत लगती है
कमांड को डिस्कस कर रहा होता हूं की आप भी
सोची होगी यह चीज क्या चल रही है ओके क्या
मुझे पता क्या यह कमांड मुझे पता है या
नहीं पता है वह चीज आपको दिमाग में
ऑटोमेटेकली ए जानी चाहिए अगर आपके दिमाग
में इसका मतलब परफेक्टली इधर कमांड
एडरवाइज नहीं आए तो सोच लो कुछ तो लोका है
आपको फिर से करना ही चाहिए मैं आपको
एडवाइस करूंगा पर्सनल एडवाइस
लेकिन हमें बिल्कुल जीरो से कैसे डिलीवरी
करना है क्योंकि बहुत से लोग ऐसे भी एक
लाइव
15 लोगों को हमें सीखना है नहीं हम चाहते
हैं की जब ये सीरीज युटुब पर रहेगी जब तक
रहेगी तब तक इसमें अगर कोई फर्क
मोडिफिकेशन करना होगा तो हम करेंगे
एडरवाइज यह ऐसा कॉन्सेप्ट
करने की जरूर ही नहीं है जब भी हमारे चैनल
पर कोई आए
यहां आगे सिख के जाए ना की ऐसा लगे की बस
हमने क्या की प्रेजेंट सिनेरियो को देखते
हुए आप लोग देखते होंगे अपनी चीज डिटेल कर
रहा हूं नहीं ये हमारा कोई मोटर नहीं है
हमारा मोटो जो है फ्यूचर में कभी भी कोई
भी अगर अपने रेफरेंस के लिए इन वीडियो की
हेल्प लेट है तो उसे सीधी डायरेक्ट गाइड
में देखा हां मुझे कुछ सीखने को मिला है
क्योंकि फ्यूचर प्रूफ चीज बनाना चाहता हूं
वो हम डिलीवर करने की कोशिश करें
तो इसलिए
तो वही चीज है की आप लोगों को आप लोग
हमारी मदद कीजिए मैं आपकी मदद करूंगा तो
आज का टॉपिक हम स्टार्ट करते हैं यूजर
मैनेजमेंट बातें काफी होगी स्टार्ट करना
चाहिए क्योंकि बातें करने के लिए बहुत
टाइम
ऑलरेडी की हमने एक से डेड घंटा बात की है
काफी अपने ऑडियंस के साथ और हमने आपस में
बात की है तो वे आर फैमिली
करते हैं पहले बात सवाल
करते हैं
बहुत साड़ी डिपार्मेंट कम करते हैं कई
प्रोडक्शन एनवायरनमेंट होता है कहानी पर
टैक्स फील्ड होता है कहानी पर कुछ होता है
कहानी पर हैकर्स कम करते हैं कहानी पर कुछ
कम करते हैं अब
यूजर मैनेजमेंट की जरूर इसलिए पड़ी अब
जैसे ताक का कम है जैसे की डेवलपमेंट का
कम है तो इस डेवलपमेंट पे ही परमिशन होने
चाहिए ना इस प्रोजेक्ट के लिए उसकी परमिशन
होना चाहिए जहां उसे कम करना उधर ही
परमिशन हनी चाहिए उसके अलावा वो पूरे
सर्वर का या पूरे मशीन के एक्सेस का क्या
करेगा क्योंकि उसका वो कम नहीं है अब मैं
इस फौजी में एग्जांपल लेट हूं की अकाउंट
डिपार्मेंट है अब अकाउंट वालों को पूरा
टेक वाले डिपार्मेंट वालों की फाइल परमिशन
भी दे दूंगा तो क्या वो बेनिफिशियल है आप
लोग लगता है नहीं है क्योंकि जितना उनको
दूर तक उतना उसे करते हैं उसके अलावा
फालतू में परमिशन देना बेकार है
मैं बताता हूं तो इसलिए
रिटायरमेंट है ये आपकी फाइल रिटायरमेंट है
ये आपका इतना एरिया है आप इसमें कम कीजिए
आपकी इतनी परमीशंस है करो हमें कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है इसमें कुछ भी कम कर सकते
हो ऐसे फाइनेंस वालों को अपने परमिशन के
हिसाब से इधर यूजर इंटरफेस डिवाइड किया है
इसलिए हमें यूजर मैनेजमेंट की जरूर पड़ी
करते हैं की लाइनेक्स में ली या हर किसी
मशीन की बात करें लेकिन हम क्या ले रहे
हैं उसकी बात करने वाले हैं लिरिक्स में
जितने भी सिस्टम एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर कम करते
हैं जितने भी सिस्टम एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर लॉगिन
करते हैं पहले अपनी मशीन में चाहे वो
रीमोटली लॉगिन करें या अपने
कंपनी में जाके लॉगिन करें वो जो भी जब भी
लॉगिन करते हैं वो एजेंट प्रिविलेज यूजर
लॉगिन करते हैं
और क्या करते हैं अगर
यूजर की रिटायरमेंट है
तो क्या करते हैं की उसके लिए कुछ टूल्स
होते हैं कुछ कमांड्स होती है उन्हें का
उसे करते हैं उसे टेंपरेरी टाइम के लिए
रूट यूजर बने के लिए उसके बाद फिर से
एग्जिट कर देते हैं सो डेट की उनकी वजह से
कंपनी में या सिस्टम में प्रॉब्लम ना हो
इसलिए अब जब एक एग्जांपल लेट हूं पर
एग्जांपल आपने क्या किया की आपकी मशीन में
सुपर यूजर लॉगिन किया आगे सुपर यूजर या
रूट यूजर या एज और एडमिन लॉगिन किया जैसे
की मैंने अभी अपनी मशीन में एजेंट एडमिन
लॉगिन किया हुआ है
मैंने क्या किया यहां पर अननेसेसरी
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर होगी
है तो मेरा पूरा सिस्टम कंप्रोमाइज हो
जाएगा कैसे क्योंकि अगर इस सिस्टम में
वल्लबिलटी है क्या होना चाहिए था की अगर
इस पर यूजर
राहत सुपर यूजर नहीं होता लोग इन में तो
क्या होता है की उसे पर्टिकुलर यूजर ही
कंप्रोमाइज होता वो आपकी पुरी मशीन
इनफैक्ट होने से बैक जाति लेकिन क्या किया
हमने गलती क्या है की हर किसी को आगे ए
रूट उसे परमिशन दे दी पूरा पूरा डेस्कटॉप
एनवायरनमेंट में कम थोड़ा सा हो रहा है और
फालतू में हमने उसको क्या किया की
रिलीज दे दिया पूरा
एडमिन बना के छोड़ दिया उसको बनाकर छोड़
दिया तो हुआ क्या है
आपकी एंटीरे मशीन को कंप्रोमाइज करवा दिया
तो यह चीज है एक
जो आपको ध्यान में रखती चाहिए जब भी आप
अपने रिलैक्स मशीन को उसे करते हैं
अब जैसे की एक चीज बताता हूं आपको मोस्ट
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम होते हैं सभी के सभी उनका
एक सुपर यूजर होता है एक रूट यूजर होता है
जिसके पास वो साड़ी पावर होती है सिस्टम
के ऊपर मतलब यह यूजर सिस्टम
है जो प्रीवियस सिस्टम है वो अगर उसको
मैनेजमेंट का कम करना है या
एडमिनिस्ट्रेशन का कम करना है तो वो जो
ऑलरेडी प्रिविलेज उसे उन प्रिविलेज यूजर
है जो नॉर्मल प्रिविलेज यूजर है उनकी
परमिशन को उनके प्रिविलेज को क्या कर सकता
है ओवरराइड कर सकता है
उसे मैनेजमेंट या एडमिनिस्ट्रेशन के हिसाब
से उसे लगता है की नहीं इस यूजर को यह
परमिशन नहीं हनी चाहिए यह गलत कर रहा है
तो वह सुपर यूजर वो उसको ओवरराइट कर सकता
है स्टॉप कर सकता है तो हम बोलते हैं की
रूट यूजर एक के पास क्या होती है
अनलिमिटेड पावर होती है वह किसी भी फाइल
को रिमूव कर सकता है डिलीट कर सकता है
कुछ भी कर सकता है इसलिए एक बात सोचिए अगर
किसी ने किसी अकाउंट को कंप्रोमाइज कर
लिया तो मतलब हमारा पूरे सिस्टम और
कंट्रोल उसके पास गया
हमें बहुत साड़ी प्रॉब्लम्स हो शक्ति
प्रॉब्लम के पूरा कंप्रोमाइज कर दिया अब
हम उसके ओनर नहीं है तो जब भी कभी आप
ईटीएफ खेलोगे या आप कोई एग्जाम डॉग किसी
भी पेन टेस्टिंग का कुछ भी करोगे तो जब आप
एन्यूमरेशन के बाद स्कैनिंग करने के बाद
जब आप रिलिजन की बात आई है तो सिस्टम को
जब आप किसी एन किसी कहां से बोल एन
मिटेंगे तो सिस्टम में इंटर कर भी जाते
हैं तो एक नॉर्मल आपका टास्क राहत है की
आपको रूट यूजर बन्ना होता है क्योंकि ये
रूट यूजर बनोगे तभी आप उसे मशीन के साथ
पोज कर पाओगे एडरवाइज नहीं कर पाओगे
क्योंकि नॉर्मल यूजर को उतनी लेवल की
प्रमोशंस नहीं होती
ओके
पासवर्ड से रिलेटेड बातें भी हम बात
करेंगे भैया की आप ऐसे मत देखिए की बस
मुझे कमांड चाहिए और उसके बाद मैं लेकर
वॉच अभी आया मुझे कमेंट चाहिए कमेंट
देखूंगा सर मेरे को कमांड बता देंगे और
मैं चला जाऊंगा नोट हम एक प्रॉपर भी ऐसे
पढ़ने हुए जाएंगे टॉपिक को पासवर्ड
मैनेजमेंट आएगा तब भी आपको पता चल जाएगा
की पासवर्ड कैसे मैनेज किया जाता है तो
अभी के लिए हम स्टार्ट करते हैं
कैसे स्विच कर सकते हैं
कैसे उसको डिलीट कर सकते हैं कैसे ग्रुप
एड कर सकते हैं कैसे ग्रुप को डिलीट कर
सकते हैं आज का टॉपिक हमारा बेसिकली यही
है
क्योंकि बहुत ही इजी टॉपिक है किसी को आता
भी होगा किसी को नहीं भी आता होगा तो आज
इतना रहेगा उसके बाद नेक्स्ट क्लास में
मैं पहले बताता हूं जो हमारा टॉपिक रहेगा
रिलिजियस कैसमेंट करती है जो
पुरविलेज हैं की आपको पासवर्ड को कैसे
मैनेज करना है या सिस्टम में जो फाइल्स
हैं मतलब की जो उसे यूजर्स होते हैं उनके
प्रिविलेज के बड़े में बात करेंगे थोड़ी
सी तो बेसिकली ए जाएगा आपका पासवर्ड
मैनेजमेंट वाली चीज ए जाएगी कैसे आप मुझे
इनके पासवर्ड को मैनेज कर सकते हैं वो
नेक्स्ट क्लास में रहेगा क्योंकि अभी
थोड़ा सा इंटरेस्टिंग चीज आएंगे जो आपको
कुछ चीज आपको पता होंगे कुछ चीज नहीं पता
होगी चलो मैं स्टार्ट करता हूं की सबसे
पहले अगर आपको क्या करना है
की आपको यह देखना चाहता है देखना चाहते हो
की मैं जी मशीन से लॉगिन किया हूं उसका
यूजर कौन है उसका
नाम क्या है अगर मैं चेक करना चाहता हूं
तो उसके लिए मैं कैसे का सकता हूं उसके
लिए कमांड होती है
की जिसने लोग इन किया है उसका नाम रूट है
अगर आपको
मैं क्या करूंगा उसके लिए भी फिर
इंटर किया काली इसका नॉर्मल ही हो जाता है
अब अगर मुझे डिटेल इनफॉरमेशन अगर मुझे
डिटेल इनफॉरमेशन चाहिए अगर हम हम देखना
चाहते हैं की हमारी मशीन में किस-किस ने
लॉगिन किया हुआ है और कहां से किया उसके
लिए कमांड होती है वो कमांड उसके लिए होती
है कमांड यू कमांड
ये रहा अब इसने बताया की अभी आपकी मशीन
में एक ही यूजर्स है जो काली है और वो
टर्मिनल्स ट 7 उसने टर्मिनल उसे किया हुआ
है इतनी टाइमिंग्स इसमें लॉगिन किया हुआ
है ईस्ट इनफॉरमेशन साथ में अपने स्क्रीन
पे इसमें शो कर दिया अगर आप यह देखना
चाहते हो की कौन सा यूजर क्या कर रहा है
आपकी मशीन में वो देखने के लिए कमांड होती
है डब्लू
अब आपको पता चल जाएगी आपकी मशीन में कौन
सा यूजर क्या कम कर रहा है अब देखिए काली
यूजर्स है तब से लोग इन किया था उसने 1913
से इसमें मशीन में लॉगिन किया हुआ है
आइडियल सब 2 मिनट 30 सेकंड था उसके अलावा
यह 46 19 जेसीबी लॉगिन
एक्चुअल मशीन है उसे पे ब्लू कमांड फायर
करोगे तो आपको पता चल जाएगा की कौन-कौन सा
यूजर कहां से लॉगिन किया हुआ है ये
इनफॉरमेशन आपको यहां पर मिल जाएगी अब बात
करते हैं अगर मुझे पर्टिकुलर कोई यूजर्स
है उसकी इनफॉरमेशन चाहिए तो कैसे मिलती है
कमांड होती है आईडी अगर मैंने आईडी कमांड
लिखी यहां पर बहुत साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन आपको
देखने को मिल रही है की ये जो यूजर्स है
काली इसकी यूजर आईडी क्या है इसकी ग्रुप
आईडी क्या है ये कौन से ग्रुप का हिस्सा
है तो इसके ग्रुप है एक तो कल ग्रुप है
एडीएम ग्रुप है सीडी रोम फ्लॉपी पीएसईउदो
ऑडियो इन सारे ग्रुप का ये क्या है मेंबर
है तो ये साड़ी चीज आपको देखने को मिल रही
होगी अगर मुझे किसी पर्टिकुलर यूजर्स के
इनफॉरमेशन देखने हैं जैसे आइडिया करता हूं
और मेरी मशीन में एक और यूजर है एम ए एन
आई एस हा मनीष अब उसकी इनफॉरमेशन देखिए
इनफॉरमेशन देखेंगे तो देखो यह उसकी यूजर
आईडी है यह उसकी ग्रुप आईडी है यह उसका
ग्रुप है तो ये इनफॉरमेशन आपको देखने को
मिल गई डिटेल इनफॉरमेशन अगर यही चीज अगर
मैं आपको पहले भी बताऊं अगर आपको भी रेड
आते की मशीन उसे कर रहे हो और या सैंटोस
उसे कर रहे हो अगर ये इनफॉरमेशन डालोगे तो
यहां पर क्या है एक और चीज आई है
स लाइनस कांटेक्ट करके आता है जो रेड लाइट
वाली चीजों में क्या होता है की
सिक्योरिटी कॉन्टेक्स्ट होता है मतलब क्या
है की उसमें एक और लेयर कम करती है
सिक्योरिटी के लिए ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के ऊपर
वही एक चीज वो एक बहुत पावरफुल चीज है
क्योंकि वो आपके पूरे सिस्टम को एक प्रकार
से आइसोलेट करके रखती है उसकी परमिशन इतनी
डेंजरस है की मैं पहले बता दो अच्छी सी
परमिशन इतनी डेंजरस हैं की उसमें सीधा है
रूल में अगर रूल में हां है तो आप वो कम
करोगे यस है अगर ना है तो वो किसी की
चिंता कुछ भी ट्राई कर लेना
नहीं होता क्योंकि बहुत स्ट्रिक्ट है
इसलिए इंडस्ट्री या उसको ज्यादा प्रेफर
करते हैं रेड को क्योंकि उसकी सिक्योरिटी
पुलिस बहुत ज्यादा टाइट है उसमें एक लेयर
के बाद दूसरी सिक्योरिटी ए जाति है फिर
इंडस्ट्री में तो फिर फायर वाला जाति है
एंटीवायरस ए जाते हैं उसके बाद इड ए जाते
हैं आईपीएस ए जाते हैं ये साड़ी चीज ए
जाति है तो हैकर्स के लिए परेशानी होती है
इसलिए अरे यूआईडी क्या होता है यूजर आईडी
रूट के लिए जीरो इसलिए आएगा क्योंकि आपकी
मशीन में जो एडमिन होता है जो सुपरहिट
होता है उसकी यूजर आईडी जीरो होती है
नेटवर्क
ही आएंगे क्योंकि रूट इसे डी सुपर यूजर और
सबसे पहले यूजर जो रूट होता है इस की जो
सुपर यूजर है उसकी आईडी जीरो होती है दास
ए उसकी आईडी जीरो ए रही है
अब बात करते हैं कंटिन्यू करते हैं एक
किसी ने ग्रुप में मैंने देखा था और अपने
जो टेलीग्राम ग्रुप में किसी ने कुछ पूछा
था की सर मुझे यहां पर ये किसी में देखने
को मिल रहा है किसी में पूरा देखने को मिल
रहा है अब देखना वो चीज यहां पर समझ में ए
जाएगी अब मैं एक चीज बताऊं की अगर आपको एक
यूजर अकाउंट से दूसरे यूजर अकाउंट में
स्विच करना है
एक कमांड
एस यू
एस यू कमांड और
अकाउंट तू अंदर
यूजर अकाउंट से
पहले कौन सा है पहले होता है
[संगीत]
है तो क्या
वह आपको एक लॉगिन सेल प्रोवाइड करती है
क्या
न्यू यूजर आप अपनी मशीन में लॉगिन करते
हैं या जब हम किसी पर्टिकुलर यूजर से लोग
इन करते हैं तो उसका अपना एक एनवायरनमेंट
होता है किसी भी यूजर एक चीज याद रखना की
किसी भी यूजर को चाहे वो रूट यूजर हो जो
कोई भी हो उसको रन करने के लिए एक
एनवायरनमेंट चाहिए होता है समझे एक
एनवायरनमेंट चाहिए होता है और वह
एनवायरनमेंट डिफाइन राहत आपकी मशीन में जब
भी कोई एक यूजर नया आपकी मशीन में लॉगिन
कर मतलब नया यूजर क्रिएट होता है तो जब भी
कोई नए जैसे आप क्या करते हो स्टार्टिंग
में एंट्री करने को करता हूं वहां पर एक
लॉगिन चलता है यूजर नाम और पासवर्ड उसको
बोलते हैं लोग इन सेल
और नॉन लोग इन सेल क्या होता है की वहां
पर क्या हुआ की जब भी आप क्या करते हो की
लॉगिन सेल तो वो हो गया नॉन लोग इन सेल
क्या होगा उसने क्या किया की जब आप स्विच
करोगे नॉन लोग इन सेल में पासवर्ड तो
प्रॉन्प्ट करेगा उसे यूजर में स्विच करने
के लिए लेकिन क्या हुआ उसने इस शहर को उसे
किया जी शहर में प्रेजेंटली अब कम कर रहे
थे क्या होता है की अगर जी सेल में कम कर
रहा हूं उसके लिए कमांड होती है अगर आपको
अपने सेल का लेवल चेक करना है तो उसके लिए
कमांड होती है को
डॉलर
सेल लेवल करके कमांड होती है
देखो अभी आपको जो प्रोवाइड दिखा रहा है ना
यह सेल लेवल यह बैंड है मतलब यह एक और शहर
एक ही सेल है अगर इसके अंदर आप लोग इन
करते हो या क्या करते हो एक और दूसरा सेल
ओपन कर दे तो यहां पर क्या है इसकी
क्वांटिटी जो संख्या है वो बाढ़ जाति है
वन से तू हो जाति है मतलब एक सेल के अंदर
दूसरा सेल आपने ओपन किया हुआ है तो सिंपली
आपको समझ में ए गया एक लोग इन सेल और नॉन
लोग इन सेल क्या होता है लोग इन सेल वह
होता है जब भी आप एक नया यूजर्स क्या होता
है जबकि आपकी मशीन में इंटर करता है तो वो
एक लॉगिन पासवर्ड डालता है उसके बाद क्या
होता है की जब इंटर कर लिया उसका एक
एनवायरनमेंट होता है उसके एनवायरनमेंट
वैरियेबल्स होते हैं जो उसको रन करने के
लिए चाहिए होते हैं वो उन्हें के साथ लोग
इन करता है लेकिन नॉन लोग इन सेल में क्या
करते हो की जी यूजर अकाउंट के साथ आप कम
कर रहे थे इस यूजर अकाउंट में जब आप क्या
है की किसी दूसरे अकाउंट में स्विच करते
हैं तो आप क्या करते हो की विदाउट ड्रेस
ऑप्शन उसे करते करते हो तो आप जस्ट
एक्टिंग कर रहे हो उसे यूजर की लेकिन जो
एनवायरनमेंट है जो एनवायरनमेंट वैरियेबल्स
हैं या जो एनवायरनमेंट है वो उसे हो रहा
है पहले वाले यूजेस का अगेन मैं रिपीट कर
रहा हूं की ओनली स कमांड के साथ अगर आप
स्विच करोगे आप क्या कर रहे हो उसे यूजर
की तरह एक्टिंग कर रहे हो लेकिन जो पूरा
एनवायरनमेंट है जो पहले वाली यूजर्स ने
सेटअप किया हुआ है पहले वाले यूजर पे कर
रहे थे एनवायरनमेंट पूरा इस का उसे कर रहे
हो मतलब आप परमानेंटली उसमें लॉगिन नहीं
कर रहे हो बेसिकली अगर आप उसे करोगे इसका
मतलब क्या है परमानेंटली लोग इन कर रहे हो
मतलब जैसा की जब आपने मशीन में जब स्विच
ऑन की होगी जो लोग इन स्क्रीन आई है लॉगिन
यूजरनेम पासवर्ड डालते हो उसके बाद आप
अपने एनवायरनमेंट वेरिएबल के साथ एंट्री
करते हो उसे टाइप का एनवायरनमेंट यह
प्रोवाइड करता है उसे टाइप से लॉगिन करते
हो तो इन दोनों में यह डिफरेंस था आपको और
जो मेरे भाई किसी ने मुझे उदय पूछा था
ग्रुप में की सर हमें ऐसा देखने को क्यों
मिलता है जैसे की जैसे मैं अब यहां पर
क्या है एस यू क्रिया मैंने स किया और
सिंपली मैं क्या कर दिया सीधा डांस कर
दिया
अब यहां पे हम क्या करते हैं अपना पासवर्ड
दाल दिया
अब यहां पर बोला की सर इधर यह देखने वाला
इधर ऐसे क्यों देगा क्योंकि यह बात समझिए
यहां पर
एक्टिंग कर रहा है स कमांड यहां पर मैंने
यूजर का नाम लिखा नहीं क्यों नहीं लिखा
क्योंकि बाय डिफॉल्टर अगर ये जो डिफाइन
नहीं करता तो बाय डिफॉल्टर ये रूट यूजर
समझना है इधर तो इसने क्या किया ये रूट
यूजर है लेकिन जो एनवायरनमेंट वैरियेबल्स
हैं वो उसे काली यूजर उसे कर रहा है काली
यूजर्स के एनवायरनमेंट वैरियेबल्स उसे कर
रहा है और इसलिए यहां पर आया की मैं ओम
डायरेक्टर ऑफ काली में हूं ना की मेरी होम
डायरेक्टरी में हूं रूट की मैं इसलिए यहां
पर यह आपको प्रेजेंट वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी
शो कर रहा है क्योंकि यहां पर आपने
नॉर्मली ओनली स कमांड का उसे किया है अगर
मैं क्या करता हूं यहां पर एग्जिट करता
हूं अब मैं डायरेक्ट सुलोच यू उसके बाद
दास करता हूं
मैंने लिखा रूट अगर पूरा लिखना हूं इंटर
यूजर क्योंकि अब इसने परमानेंट उसके अंदर
शिफ्ट कर लिया है उसे यूजर अकाउंट में जो
रूट यूजर है अभी ये क्या है इसी का उसे
अकाउंट है इसी के एनवायरनमेंट वैरियेबल्स
उसे कर रहा अब ये एक्टिंग नहीं कर रहा है
अब ये परमानेंट है
ये चीज समझ में ए रही होगी की
एस यू कमांड का मतलब क्या
मतलब क्या हो गया
सर
जो कमेंट्स आपकी लास्ट में लूंगा मैं नो
नो
5 मिनट बोलना तो आपकी जो डाउट है एक बार
पूछ रहे हैं लास्ट के 5 मिनट आपको मैं
प्रोवाइड करूंगा तो क्योंकि अभी क्या
कॉन्सेप्ट से है थोड़ा डिफरेंटशिएट हो
जाऊंगा तो प्रॉब्लम होगी क्योंकि मैं जो
फ्लो है वो टूट जाएगा तो अब बात करते हैं
की आपको मैंने समझाया की स कमांडो को कैसे
उसे करते हैं कमांड को कैसे उसे कर सकते
हैं या आप करके देखिए आपको पता चल जाएगा
डिफरेंस सही होता है मैंने आपके सामने
करके दिखाए सुडो सिंपली स करते हैं तो आप
उसे एक्टिंग कर रहे हो पुरी तरह वो यूजर
नहीं हो अगर आप दास के साथ किसी यूजर के
मैं इंटर करें इसका मतलब उसके टोटली आप वो
यूजर बन के इंटर कर रहे हो
मतलब एनवायरनमेंट
के बड़े में अब मुझे लगता है की इसके बड़े
में आप ज्यादा आपको प्रैक्टिकल करके
दिखाने की मुझे जरूर नहीं है अगर मुझे
जरूर भी है तो अगर मैं आपको दिखाऊं चलो
मैं एक कम करके दिखा देता हूं
ओके मैं एग्जिट करता हूं सिंपली एलएस करता
हूं ये रहा अब यहां पर होती है एलएस बस
प्रोफाइल ओके यहां पर कुछ है क्या
फाइल ओके ओके ओके ओके
ओके मैं फिर से कम करता हूं छोड़ो एस यू
ल एस करता हूं यहां पर मुझे कुछ देखने को
नहीं मिल रहा है
[संगीत]
वह चीज मुझे मिल नहीं रही आपको दिखाने की
कोशिश कर रहा हूं क्योंकि मेरी मशीन थोड़ी
सी मॉडिफाइड है मैं थोड़ी सी इसमें चेंज
किया हुए हैं ओके वैसे कॉन्सेप्ट
[संगीत]
पटना है उससे रिलेटेड भी
तो वह भी हम डिस्कस करने वाले हैं तो चलो
फिर हम कंटिन्यू करते हैं टाइम वेस्ट नहीं
करेंगे तब यूजर को मैनेज कैसे किया जाता
है यूजर को मैनेज कैसे किया जाता है तो
अगर जैसे एक फाइल होती है
समझने की कोशिश करता हूं यह पुरी एंट्री
में क्या है क्योंकि अगर आपको यूजर
मैनेजमेंट करना है तो आपको इस एंट्री को
समझना बहुत ज्यादा जरूरी है
और एक बार मैं क्या करता हूं यह ओके
देन गैस यस ओके
पासवर्ड
है क्योंकि पहले क्या होता था
लेकिन दिउ तू सिक्योरिटी रीजंस की जगह
सीटीसी के अंदर एक शैडो फाइल
देखने को मिलता है
उसके बाद
उसके बाद हम करते हैं इसकी थर्ड जो एंट्री
है आपको दिखाई दे रही होगी
को मिलती है इसका मतलब क्या है यह आपको शो
कर रहा है की यह आपकी यूजर आईडी है यूजर
आईडी हर एक यूजर की अपनी एक यूनिट वगैरा
दी होती है जब यूनिक आईडी होती है जब भी
एक यूजर क्रेडिट किया जाता किया जाता है
आपकी मशीन में उसकी आईडी उसके अकॉर्डिंग
उसको असाइन कर दी जाति है नेक्स्ट आपको
देखने को मिल रहा है एक और वन वन जीरो तू
ये उसकी जी यूआईडी ग्रुप आईडी को शो कर
रहा है ग्रुप आईडी को रिप्रेजेंट कर रहा
है नेक्स्ट जो आपको देखने को मिल रहा है
यहां पर
देता हूं यहां पर जो स्पेस दिखाए है यहां
पर क्या होता है अभी मैं स्पेस की जगह कर
देता हूं ये रहा
ओके
यहां पर जो एंट्री है यह यहां पर लोकेशन
एंट्री पर कमेंट्स कमेंट का मतलब क्या है
की आप अगर कुछ चीज इसको मनीष यूजर है इसके
लिए कुछ ऐसा टैग रखना चाहता है की आप उसको
याद रखो की हां यह किस लिए है ऐसा कुछ
कमेंट देना चाहते तो इसके अंदर वो देखने
को मिलता है नेक्स्ट आपको देखने को मिल
रहा है स्लैश सोंग्स स्लैश मनीष मनीष अगर
आपको यह देखने को मिल रहा है इसका मतलब
क्या है या इसको रिप्रेजेंट करता है
कंट्रोल भी
आपके रिप्रेजेंट करता है
लोकेशन ऑफ होम डायरेक्टरी इस यूजर्स की
होम डायरेक्टरी क्या है लोकेशन ऑफ
डायरेक्टर
कौन से शहर
मतलब की जो जी मशीन में कम करते हो जब आप
इसके अंदर स्विच करोगे तो कौन सी सेल्फी
करेगा ये उसकी इनफॉरमेशन यहां पर होती है
ये साड़ी एंट्री है
जो मैंने डिटेल में लिख दिया है इस फिल्म
के ऊपर आई होप की आपको सबको समझ में ए रहा
होगा अभी
एक चीज ध्यान में रखिए जब भी आप यूजर एड
करते हैं अब ये तो है आपको बता दिया मैं
बताता हूं तो आयोग में इसको क्या करता हूं
अभी बैंड कर देता हूं अब हम नॉर्मली यूजर
एड करते वक्त कैसे करते हैं मैंने क्या
किया पहले यूजर एड किया यूजर एड और मैंने
लिखा यूजर वन सिंपली इंटर कर दिया अब
मैंने उसे रेड तो कर दिया उसे सिंपली लिख
दिया अब क्या करोगे जब मैं क्या करता हूं
तेल करता हूं और लास्ट की दो एंट्री देखना
चाहता हूं स्लैश ईटीसी पास डी फाइल इस
फाइल में आगे इसके एंट्री बन जाति है
इंटर यहां पर आपको देखने को मिल रहा है
यूजर वन पासवर्ड
1004 यह आईडी है इसका हम कमेंट इसमें दिया
नहीं है ये इसकी होम डायरेक्टली ये इसका
सेल कौन सा है
उसके लिए जो फाइंड एनवायरनमेंट वैरियेबल्स
हैं
है इसलिए
असाइन कर दिया इसको चाहे तो चेंज कर सकते
हो लेकिन क्या होता है की मैं एक चीज आपको
एडवाइस करूंगा जब भी आप किसी यूजर को इडली
एड करते हो तो आपको उसकी पुरी डिटेल
इनफॉरमेशन मेंशन करनी चाहिए जितनी आपको
लगता है हो सकता है की आपने इधर एड किया
और आपकी जो एक डायरेक्टली होती है जहां से
बाय डिफॉल्टर यह चीज आई हैं हम आपको कुछ
गड़बड़ है या कोई प्रॉब्लम्स है तो हो
सकता है की उसकी वजह से कुछ चीज इसके साथ
में चेंज नहीं होगी जो बेसिकली उसकी होम
डायरेक्टरी होती है उसका सेल होता है कुछ
कमेंट होता है उसके जो नाम हो गया यह
साड़ी चीज क्या है आपको अगर ध्यान में
रखते हुए अगर आप मॉडिफाइड में स्टार्टिंग
से ही अगर इडली पूरा क्या करोगे अगर एड
करोगे तो आपको क्या है इसका बेनिफिट अच्छे
मिलेगा क्योंकि हो सकता है की कोई
प्रॉब्लम होगी तो प्रॉब्लम कर देगा जैसे
की क्या मैं कहना चाहता हूं मैंने यूजर एड
किया है
जिसका नाम है तू उसे एड करना चाहता हूं
लेकिन मैं अब क्या कहना चाहता हूं मतलब
मॉडिफाई परमिशन मुझे बाय डिफॉल्ट वाली
नहीं चाहिए मैं जो पहले बोल रहा हूं
मॉडिफाइड वो परमिशन डालिए उसके बाद जो बैक
जाता है बाय डिफॉल्टर वो आप इसमें एड कर
दीजिए
मॉडिफाई ऑप्शन दी मैं चाहता हूं यहां पर
दी मतलब होम डायरेक्टरी कौन सी देना चाहता
हूं मैं सिंपली होम राइट दिया जाता हूं
होम के अंदर कौन सी यू एस ए आर यूजर 2 ही
रखना चाहता हूं उसके बाद हायफेंसी
हायफेंसी का मतलब मैं कमेंट देना चाहता
हूं क्या कमेंट देना चाहता हूं
देखिए
इसके होम डायरेक्टरी है यहां पर
देखने को मिल रहा होगा तो इस तरीके से दिस
इसे डी बेस्ट वे आपको करना चाहिए
और उसके बाद
अब क्या होता है की यह तो मैंने बताया की
जब भी हम कोई यूजर एड करते हैं तो
ऑटोमेटेकली सिस्टम क्या है
अब मैंने देखो की मॉडिफाइड भी क्या लेकिन
फिर भी इसके सामने बहुत साड़ी चीज आएगी
अगर ये देखना चाहते हो की ये डिफॉल्ट
एंट्री कहां से आई है इसके अंदर अगर ये
चीज देखना चाहते हैं तो उसके लिए एक
डायरेक्टरी होती है कैट करता हूं स्लैश
ईटीसी के अंदर एक डिफॉल्ट नाम की
डायरेक्टर होती है उसके अंदर एक ये जो रेड
होती है इसके अंदर वो चीज डिफाइंड है जब
भी कोई नया एड होगा तो बाय डिफॉल्टर उसके
ऊपर क्या चीज है आएंगे जैसे की रिपोर्ट
यूजर है उसका क्या है डिफॉल्ट सेल स्लैश
बिन से आएगा जो हमारे पास आया उसके बाद
उसकी स्टार्टिंग क्या होगी 100 जिसने दिया
उसके बाद 1 2 3 4 लगे डाइमेंशन सिस्टम के
लिए ग्रुप और उसकी होम डायरेक्टरी कैसे
स्टोर होगी देखो फॉर्म होगी स्लैश होम
उसके बाद उसका नाम उसके बाद ये क्या है
नंबर ऑफ डेज आपके पासवर्ड
डिसएबल अब यह बोल रहा है की जब भी कोई नया
यूजर एड होगा तो उसका पासवर्ड क्या आप
फिक्स करना चाहते हो की इतने दिन के बाद
वो एक्सपायर हो जाए यहां पर लिखा माइंस वन
ये कभी भी एक्सपायर नहीं होगा अब डिफॉल्ट
एक्सपायरी डेट यू जस्ट अभी तक हमने क्या
ये जो यूजर एड किया है इसकी कोई भी
एक्सपायर डेट एड नहीं है मतलब डिफॉल्ट है
नहीं है और एक और चीज है यहां पे एक ये
चीज एस के स्काल्ड रिक्रूटमेंट इसके बड़े
में थोड़ी सी मैं बताऊंगा अभी थोड़ी डर
में लेकिन एक स्केल डायरेक्टर में बेसिकली
क्या चीज होती है मैं जस्ट थोड़ा सा मुझे
दो कॉन्सेप्ट पर चलते चलते अभी स्किल्ड
छोटी सी कंट्रोल में आपको बताऊंगा तो ये
वो स्केल डायरेक्टली से कुछ चीज उठाता है
तो ये साड़ी चीज बाय डिफॉल्टर जब भी आप एक
यूजर एड करते हो वो यहां से वो साड़ी
डिटेल उसे करके बाद ऑटोमेटेकली एड हो जाति
है इस कमांड के साथ क्योंकि यहां पे
बाइनरी है एक प्रोग्राम देखा गया है
प्रोग्राम में ये लिखा है की आपको कहां से
क्या चीज लेनी है बाय डिफॉल्टर अगर
मॉडिफाई आता है तो पहले वो एड करना उसके
बाद चीज उसके पास रखती है ये प्रोग्राम का
मतलब है आई होप सबको यहां तक समझ में ए
रहा होगा की मुझे क्या मैंने क्या किया और
मैं यहां क्या करना छह रहा था एक चीज
बताता हूं की अगर आप किसी भी यूजर को
मॉडिफाई करना चाहते हो अगर किसी यूजर की
डीटेल्स को आप मॉडिफाई करना चाहते हो
सिंपली जैसे की मैं तेल करता हूं
मैं क्या चाहता हूं की स्लैश बिंदु एसेस
है इस वाले को मॉडिफाई में बेस्ट सेल देना
चाहता हूं इसको तो कैसे करेंगे आप सिंपली
कमांड करोगे यूजर मोड यूजर मोड मतलब यूजर
का मॉडिफाई करना चाहता हूं हाय फांसी मतलब
उसके कमेंट क्या देना चाहता हूं एक तो
कमेंट एड करना चाहता हूं कमेंट क्या है
इसके लिए कमेंट है
कमेंट में रखा जाता हूं
दिस इसे मी
डेमो पर
बेस्ट सेल मैं इसके कमेंट
करना चाहता हूं कौन सा जो मॉडिफाइड
करना चाहता हूं उसके बाद में यूजर का नाम
यूजर का नाम क्या है यूजर तू सिंपली हिट
इंटर अगर अब ये इनफॉरमेशन तेल कमांड करके
देखोगे आपको आपको देखने को मिलेगी यस ये
था यूजर तू है दिस इसे मी डेमो पर बेस्ट
सेल दें ये उसकी होम डायरेक्टरी ये इसका
सेल चेंज हो गया तो इस तरीके से आप यूजर
मोड कमांड का उसे करके क्या कर सकते हो
इसकी इसमें मोडिफिकेशन कर सकते हो अगर
इसके साथ क्या-क्या ऑप्शन उसे कर सकते हो
उसके लिए कमांड होती है
जैसे जैसे आप इसको उसे करना शुरू करो या
ऐसे-ऐसे|
उसके लिए कमांड होती है यूजर
कमांडर कर दिया
अब मैं क्या करता हूं अगर मैं सीडी करता
हूं
डायरेक्टर
दिया यहां पर एलएस करता हूं यहां पर देखो
मैंने क्या किया यूजर तू को डिलीट कर दिया
फिर भी यहां पर आपको यूजर तू भी होम
डायरेक्टर देखने को मिल रही है क्यों
क्योंकि हुआ
उसे किया था उसने यूजर को कहां से डिलीट
कर दिया सिस्टम से डिलीट हो गया
लेकिन उसका जो होम अकाउंट था वह अभी तक
डिलीट नहीं हुआ उसकी होम डायरेक्टरी अभी
तक डिलीट नहीं हुई अगर आप उसकी होम
डायरेक्टरी को भी साथ में डिलीट करना
चाहते हो तो कैसे करोगे जब भी आप क्या
करोगे
सिंपली अभी मैं आता हूं क्या करूंगा
एफ आर ओके अब यह कम कर गया
तो अभी मैं आपको दिखता हूं तो अगर मैं
क्या करता हूं की यूजर
डेल कमांड उसे करता हूं हिफिन आर के साथ
और यूजर वन
ओके यूजर ए गया
ओके तेल तू तेल तू तेल तू तेल तू
वन है नहीं हमने बनाया था
ओके
उसे करोगे तो क्या होगा वो होम डायरेक्टर
के साथ डिलीट हो जाएगा अब यहां पर ये एक
चीज मेरी तरफ से वार्निंग समझिए तब बहुत
सारे बुक्स में भी आपको देखने को मिलेगा
ये चीज आपको ध्यान में रखती है जब भी किसी
भी यूजर को डिलीट कर रहे होते हैं आप
स्पेशली पहले बात तो जब भी किसी यूजर को
डिलीट करने वाले हो तो पहले उसके होम
डायरेक्टरी चेक कर लीजिए की उसमें क्या
कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट चीज हैं या है या नहीं है
क्या उसमें कोई इंपॉर्टेंट चीज है या नहीं
है आपको लगता है की कुछ स्पेसिफिक
इंपॉर्टेंट चीज हैं तो उसको ट्रांसफर कर
लीजिए अगर वह बेकार की चीज आपको लगता है
की नहीं डिलीट करने से कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं
होगी तो आपको क्या करना है उसको डिलीट
करना है हिफिन आर लगा के अब इसके करण क्या
प्रॉब्लम हो शक्ति है
फादर विदाउट हिफिन आर आप ऑप्शन स्पेसिफाइड
किया बगैर किसी भी यूजर को डिलीट कर दे हो
तो अगर उसकी डायरेक्टरी में कुछ सेंसेटिव
इनफॉरमेशन है वो वहां पर बन जाति है
क्योंकि डायरेक्टर की इनफॉरमेशन बैक गई है
यूजर डिलीट हो गया है और एक चीज ध्यान
रखना जब भी कोई उसे डिलीट होता है तो
उसके जो अगेन जो आईडी असाइन थी यूआईडी वह
क्या हो जाति है फ्री हो जाति है और लेकिन
होम डायरेक्टरी उसकी अभी तक क्या है होम
डायरेक्टरी भी क्रीटेड है और उसमें क्या
है सेंसेटिव इनफॉरमेशन तो यहां पे एक
सिक्योरिटी पॉइंट इस होता है की लिक ऑफ
सेंसेटिव इनफॉरमेशन लीड तू सेंसेटिव
इनफॉरमेशन लीकेज और अदर सिक्योरिटी
हो सकते हैं जैसे क्या होता है जब भी आप
कोई भी नए यूजर एड करते हो तो उसको जो
आइडिया साइन की जाति है वो वो इतिहास और
की जाति है जो फ्री होती है सिस्टम में जो
सबसे पहले फ्री आईडी हो सकता है की जब
आपने यूजर डिफाइन किया भाई डिफॉल्ट हाल और
हो सकता है की यूजर नाम भी आपको लगभग से
हो गया तो हो सकता है की सिस्टम ने क्या
किया है की जो आईडी उसे यूजर को डिफाइन थी
जो डिलीट किया रिलीज कर दिया वो आईडी इसको
साइन कर दी तो इसकी जो फाइल थी जो होम
डायरेक्टरी यूजर्स की उसकी फाइल्स की जो
परमिशन थी नए वाले जो साइन हुआ एड हुआ
उसकी परमिशन के साथ वो अपडेट हो जाएगी तो
इसका मतलब सिंपली क्या है की उसकी जो
सेंसेटिव इनफॉरमेशन है वो यूजर जो नया एड
हुआ है जिसको वो आइडिया साइन हो रही है वो
उसको एक्सेस कर सकता है यहां पर ये एक
सिक्योरिटी इशू हो सकता है दूसरा क्या है
की जब भी आप एड कर सकते हो जब तो तो जब तक
आप आईफोन यू ऑप्शन उसके साथ डिफाइन नहीं
करूं तब तक आप उसको क्या है की मैन्युअल
आईडी असाइन नहीं कर सकते तब तो बाय
डिफॉल्टर ही लेट है तो इसलिए यहां के यह
सेंसेटिव इनफॉरमेशन का अब कोई हो सकता है
की मैंने अटैक कर रहा हूं मैंने पढ़ लिया
जस्ट की रेसिंग टेक्निक को उसे किया और
मैं कैसे ना कैसे नॉर्मल यूजर बन गया और
मैं यूजर की होम डायरेक्टरी में गया है
वहां पर मुझे कुछ एंट्री दिखे गई ओके
यूजर्स हैं और मुझे मैंने क्या है की
फाइंड करने की कोशिश की एक कमांड होती
फाइंड एक कमांड उससे और वो कमांड क्या है
उसे यूजर को एक्सेस है उसमें कोशिश की की
क्या पूरे रूट पार्टीशन में क्या कोई ऐसी
फाइल पड़ी है जिसका कोई मी आप नहीं है कोई
यूआईडी नहीं है पता चला की ओके एक यूजर
मिल गया तो क्या करेगा एक नया यूजर एड
करने को सब्सक्राइब
कर सकता है
तो यहां पर दो ऑप्शन है यहां पर सिचुएशन
के हिसाब से दो सॉल्यूशन आपके पास एक
सॉल्यूशन ये है की आप क्या है उसका डाटा
निकालिए और उसको डिलीट कर दीजिए दूसरा
क्या है
मैन्युअल क्या है डाटा को ट्रांसफर कर
लीजिए अगर ऐसा कुछ छोड़ देते हो या उसको
करना है तो उसको पूरा नाम चेंज कर दीजिए
उसको किसी और को साइन कर दीजिए
प्रैक्टिकल दिखाने के लिए ब्रो अभी आई
थिंक इतना ज्यादा टाइम है नहीं हमारे पास
बट आई बिल ट्री मी बेस्ट की जब हमारे पास
टाइम राहत रहेगा तो आई बिल ट्राई की आपको
प्रैक्टिकल दिखा ओके आई बिल ड्राइव
क्योंकि जो मुझे कैप्सूल कोर्स में आपको
कर करवाना है लेट्स बहुत ज्यादा करवाना है
एक कम कीजिए आप पहले खुद से ट्राई करके
देखिए अगर आप लोगों से नहीं होता है तो हम
कैप्शन में रहते हो उसके बाद हम ट्राई कर
सकते हैं की हमें क्या करना है ओके तो
उसके बाद हम ट्राई कर सकते हैं
तो अब बात करते हैं की कंटिन्यू करते हैं
तो आपको पता चल गया की कैसे किसी भी यूजर
को आपको मॉडिफाई करना है कैसे उसको डिलीट
करना है कैसे उसके अंदर मतलब किन चीजों को
ध्यान रखना है अब मैं बात करता हूं की एक
डायरेक्टर की बात हुई थी कौन सी
वाली है
ये क्या होती है
जब भी हम कोई नया यूजर अकाउंट क्रिएट करते
हैं हमारी मशीन में तो बहुत सारे कंटेंट्स
जो इस डायरेक्टर के अंदर है वो ऑटोमेटेकली
कॉपी हो जाते हैं आपकी यूजर ऑन यूजर
अकाउंट की डायरेक्टरी में
मतलब क्या है की जब एक यूजर क्रिएट होगा
ना तो उसके एक ढांचा तैयार किया इन इन
चीजों की रिटायरमेंट हुई ये चीज उसके पास
हनी चाहिए या आपने क्या किया की आप एक
एडमिन अकाउंट एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर की ड्यूटी कर
रहे हो लेने एक्साइड मेंस की और जब आप
वहां कंप्लीट नहीं जाते हो तो आपकी एक
आइडिया की रीड की बोला ये आपकी यूजर आईडी
है आप इसके थ्रू भी अपनी मशीन में कम कर
सकते हो अब उसकी सिस्टम की जो पॉलिसी होगी
उसे करने की वो हर किसी को जाके तो आप
बताओगे नहीं या तो आपकी लेटर में होगी
एडरवाइज क्या होता है की आप क्या करते हो
की जब जैसे लोग इन करोगे तो वहां पे कुछ
न्यूज़ डोंट के लिए साथ आएगी आपको क्या
करना है क्या नहीं करना है तो वो चीज कहां
रहती है वो चीज कहां रहती है वो चीज स्केल
डायरेक्टरी होती है और कुछ प्रोफाइल
फाइल्स होती हैं उन्हें के अंदर मेंस रहती
है जैसे ही आप आपका अकाउंट क्रिएट होगा वो
बाय डिफॉल्टर आपके सामने अकाउंट में लोड
हो जाएंगे जब भी आप उसको मशीन को उसे करता
हूं आपके सामने वार्निंग पोस्ट ये साड़ी
चीज बाय डिफॉल्ट यही से आते हैं
तो जो बाय डिफॉल्ट एक एनवायरनमेंट टाइप
कीजिए जो किसी पर्टिकुलर को कम करने के
लिए चाहिए वो स्केल डायरेक्टर के अंदर
डिफाइंड रहती है जो स्केल डायरेक्टली अगर
मैं सीडी करता हूं सीडी स्लैश ईटीसी के
अंदर और स्क्वायर
यह जो साड़ी चीज
साड़ी चीज बाई डिफॉल्ट क्या है आपकी होम
एक कम करता हूं शिरडी करता हूं
देखो यह वाली चीज जो बेस्ट वाली होगी दो
चीज
ऑटोमेटेकली इसके साथ वो ए गई है
इसके साथ आज अधिक क्रोम क्यों आई क्योंकि
ये जो चीज थी यह सकल डायरेक्टरी में मेंशन
थी वो साड़ी की साड़ी इसमें ए जाएंगे अगर
आपको यकीन नहीं होता तो मैं कम करता हूं
आपके सामने एक यूजर एड करता हूं उसका नाम
रखा मैंने अभी रखना हूं मैं स्वयं रखना
हूं और सिंपली हिट इंटर कर दिया अब मैं
स्विच करता हूं
और स्विच करता हूं मैं
कहां पर हूं
चेंज डायरेक्टर तू होम
डायरेक्टरी ओके एग्जिट करते हैं
हम इसको देखना पड़ेगा इसमें
तो उसका पासवर्ड मेंशन नहीं है अभी तो मैं
जैसे मेरे पास क्या है तेल करता हूं मेरे
पास मनीष वाली जो चीज थी मर्सिडीज़ कर रहा
हूं सोडो और कू करता हूं और मनीष
किया मैंने और मैं इसके अंदर तो मैं पीडी
करूंगा रूट है मेरा आगे हम इसका सीडी
ऑन जाता हूं मैं इसके में और
डायरेक्ट भी होम इस वही वही वही वही वही
वही वही
पीडी ओके
ओम काली ओके
प्रॉब्लम है क्योंकि इस सिक्योरिटी
करोगे वो आपको देखने को मिलेगा
एग्जिट कर देता हूं और खाली पैलेस करता
हूं
देखो यहां भी वो स्केल डायरेक्टली वाली
चीज आपको देखने को मिलेगी डॉट बेस्ट लोग
आउट डॉट बेस्ट आरसी डॉट ऑर्जिनल
आपको इधर भी देखने को मिलेगी तो ये साड़ी
चीज डायरेक्टर के अंदर थी तो इस प्रकार से
हम क्या कर सकते हैं
अब मत दिखता हूं आपको अगर किसी ग्रुप को
एड करना है तो हम कैसे कर सकते हैं
क्योंकि आज कर लेते हैं 10 मिनट में हो
जाएगा क्योंकि आज नहीं किया तो फिर फालतू
में हमें दोबारा से पढ़ना पड़ेगा इसी के
अंदर टॉपिक स्टार्ट कर पाएंगे कल तो
साथ में करें क्या बताओ कमेंट में बता
दीजिए
ग्रुप मैनेजमेंट लोकल ग्रुप मैनेजमेंट
कैसे करते हैं ज्यादा टाइम तो लगेगा नहीं
बताओ बताओ
चलो देखो अब ग्रुप मैनेजमेंट की बात करते
हैं
अब अगर देखो अब क्या होता है
तो मैं ऐसा तो नहीं करूंगी
यह देने की बजे मैं क्या कर सकता हूं मैं
सिंपली क्या कहूंगा एक ग्रुप बनाऊंगा उन
लोगों का और उसे ग्रुप में उन ग्रुप में
जितने मेंबर्स होगी उन मेंबर्स को उन
पर्टिकुलर फाइल पे पांच फाइल हैं छह फाइल
हैं या साथ है उनको परमिशन डिफाइन कर
दूंगा और उसे फाइल का जो ग्रुप होगा या
डायरेक्टली जो ग्रुप होगा उसको ग्रुप को
उसमें एड कर देंगे तो उससे क्या होगा उसके
डायरेक्टर या उसे प्रोजेक्ट के अंदर जो
फाइल थी उसकी परमिशन उन सभी मेंबर को एक
साथ मिल जाएगी और मुझे इन फ्यूचर कोई एड
करना हो सिंपली कुछ ग्रुप का मेंबर
बनाऊंगा अगर मुझे किसी को चाहिए की नहीं
अब इसका कम अब इसकी जरूर नहीं है दोनों
सिंपली इस ग्रुप से उसे बंदे को
नंबर को रिमूव कर दूंगा तो सारे कम आसन हो
जाएंगे क्यों मैं 100 टाइम्स परमिशन दूंगा
हंड्रेड टाइम्स परमिशन को मैं रिमूव
करूंगा ये तो बड़ा टास्क है तो इसके लिए
आपकी मशीन में दो टाइप्स के ग्रुप होते
हैं
एक तो होता है आपका
प्राइमरी ग्रुप
और एक होता है आपका सेकेंडरी ग्रुप
सेकेंडरी ग्रुप
कौन सा होता है
वो उसका प्राइमरी ग्रुप होता है
अपने प्राइमरी ग्रुप का मेंबर होता है और
वह प्राइमरी ग्रुप इस के नाम से क्रिएट
होता है सेकेंडरी ग्रुप वो होता है जो
ग्रुप हम क्रिएट करते हैं अपनी सुविधा के
हिसाब से और उसको क्या करते हैं उसके अंदर
दूसरे मेंबर्स को एड करते हैं की उसे
प्रोजेक्ट के हिसाब से कम किया जा सके
इनफॉरमेशन देखनी है तो मैं क्या कर सकता
हूं सिंपली तेल किया मैंने आईफोन 5 किया
और स्लैश ईटीसी के अंदर एक ग्रुप फाइल भी
होती है एक फाइल होती है ग्रुप
देखो यहां पर
इनफॉरमेशन रहती है यह क्या है ग्रुप है
क्योंकि जो से है से ही प्राइमरी ग्रुप का
ग्रुप आईडी क्या है अगर जो सेकेंडरी ग्रुप
होंगे वो आपको यहां देखने को मिल
यहां पर सेकेंडरी ग्रुप आपको देखने को
मिलेंगे अगर मैं आपको काली की दिखता हूं
अगर मैं क्या करता हूं की कैट करता हूं
स्लैश ईटीसी
गो अप काली क्योंकि ऑलरेडी पहले बहुत सारे
ग्रुप का मेंबर था ग्रुप उसके बाद में
क्या करता हूं की रेप करता हूं ग्रुप करता
हूं खाली इसमें और ओके फिर इंटर कर देता
हूं अब देखो
काली
इतनी चीज क्या देखो काली एक ग्रुप है और
उसके यह सारे यह मेंबर्स है यह भी ग्रुप
देखो
स्कैनर है
ऐसे बॉक्स निकालो तो इस प्रकार से ये क्या
ये कालिका या साइन क्या की जब आप
कंफीग्रेशन कर रहे थे की मशीन
के हिसाब से एड हो गया है तो सेकेंडरी
ग्रुप की इनफॉरमेशन बेसिकली आपको यहां
देखने को मिलती है और यहां पर जो आपको
प्राइमरी ग्रुप देखने को मिलता है अब हम
ग्रुप कैसे एड करते हैं हम आपको दिखता हूं
क्लियर करता हूं मैं 1 मिनट
हमें ग्रुप को एड करना तो कैसे करेंगे हम
एड करते हैं अगर जैसे की मैं आपको वो चीज
बताऊंगा तो अगर मैं यूजर एड करता हूं यूजर
एड किया और सिंपली मैंने ऐसे चेंज किया
ओके अब मैं क्या करता हूं तेल करता हूं
उसके बाद हाय फैन तू सिंपल
अपने ही ग्रुप का एक मेंबर है यह आपको पता
चल गया होगा अगर मुझे हां एक चीज बता देता
हूं यहां पर आपको की किसी भी एक यूजर को
आप मल्टीपल ग्रुप में एड कर सकते हैं और
वो उसके सेकेंडरी ग्रुप कहलायेंगे किसी भी
यूजर के
और आप चाहे तो उसका प्राइमरी ग्रुप भी
चेंज कर सकते हो अगर मुझे ये देखना की मैं
किन-किन ग्रुप का मेंबर हूं रूट है जैसे
मैंने क्या किया तो ये चेक करने के लिए एक
कमांड होती है गो यूपीएस ग्रुप और हिटलर
तो ये सब अपने ही ग्रुप का मेंबर है अगर
मुझे काली जो मेरा यूजर है उसके ग्रुप देख
रहा हूं किस-किस ग्रुप का मेंबर हो सिंपली
मैं करूंगा गुरु जी आरो यूपीएस ग्रुप और
ग्रुप का नाम काली जो यूजर है
जो आपका काली यूजरना वो काली ईडीएम डायलॉग
सीडी रंग जो हमने आईडी कमांड से देखा था
[संगीत]
इतने ग्रुप कहिए मेंबर है
की आप किस किस ग्रुप के मेंबर हो देखने को
मिल जाएगी अगर आपको क्या करना है कोई भी
ग्रुप एड करना है आपकी मशीन में वो कैसे
कर सकते हो
जी आर ओ यू पी ग्रुप एड कमांड का नाम और
मैंने ग्रुप का नाम लिखा भी मैं यूनिक्स
यूनिक्स मैंने ग्रुप का नाम लिखा कैपिटल
में और अगर यह देखना मुझे तो मैं क्या
करूंगा तेल हिफिन फ्लैश सीटीसी
और ग्रुप और तेल से पहले मैं क्या करता
हूं लास्ट के दो लाइन देखनी है तो हिट
इंटर लो अभी यूनिक्स है ये ग्रुप है अभी
यूनिक्स तो है ही ग्रुप इसका कोई यूजर हो
या ना हो बट क्या आएगी इसका कोई भी अभी
मेंबर्स नहीं है ओके तो ये ग्रुप एड हो
गया है आपको पता चल गया होगा अगर मैं इसको
दिखाऊंगा एक कम करता हूं अगर तेल करता हूं
और क्या करता हूं मैं इसको
यहां पर यूनिट साइन नहीं क्योंकि ऐसा का
नाम तो कोई भी यूजर नहीं है अब मैं क्या
करना चाहता हूं की जब मैं सचिन उसे होता
सचिन तू यूजर्स आपके स्क्रीन पे दिखाई दे
रहा है मैं इसको क्या करना चाहता हूं इस
ग्रुप का मेंबर बनाना चाहता हूं मतलब जो
सचिन तू है इसका क्या करना चाहता हूं मैं
जो सेकेंडरी ग्रुप एड करना चाहता हूं उसको
सेकेंडरी को मैं एड करना चाहता हूं कैसे
करूंगा उसके लिए कमांड होती है आपकी यूजर
मोड तो की यूजर में मोडिफिकेशन कर रहे हो
ना आप तो यूजर मोड आईफोन ए ऑप्शन आईफोन ए
ऑप्शन कैपिटल जिओ ऑप्शन यहां पे एक चीज
ध्यान रखना जो हिफिन ए ऑप्शन है वो
मैंडेटरी है जब जब आप सिंपली किसी एक यूजर
को किसी ग्रुप का मेंबर बनाना चाहते हो
क्यों अगर आप क्या करना चाहते हो सिंपली
एक यूजर किसी ग्रुप का मेंबर नहीं बनाता
था की एक्जिस्टिंग जितने भी ग्रुप हैं उन
सबको हटा के उन सबको हटा दें डिलीट कर दें
मतलब डिलीट नहीं कर दे इसके इस यूजर के
लिए उन सभी ग्रुपऑन को हटा दें और सिर्फ
ये इस ग्रुप को एड करना मुझे बनाना चाहता
हूं की इस का मेंबर है तो अगर वो करना
चाहते हैं तो सिंपली आप क्या करोगे हिफिन
ए ऑप्शन को हटा दीजिए तो क्या होगा की
जितने भी एक्जिस्टिंग ग्रुप होंगे उन सबको
हटा के ये उसका मैं उसको मेंबर बना देगा
नए वाले ग्रुप का जो आप अभी ग्रुप का नाम
देखो मैंने क्या जी के पास यूनिक लिखा और
उसका नाम किसका
चिन्ह और हिट इंटर करूंगा अभी इसने क्या
किया सेकेंडरी को पद कर देगा
वो क्या करता है की इसका हिफिन ए ऑप्शन
उसे नहीं करता था क्या होता है
उनको
ओवरराइड कर देगा नए वाले ग्रुप के साथ
अब बात करते हैं
तो वह भी आप कर सकते हो
ओके तो यह आपको पता चल गया होगा की ग्रुप
को कैसे एड करना है और उसका सेकेंडरी
ग्रुप में कैसे एड करना है अगर मैं क्या
करना चाहता हूं की किसी का प्राइमरी रुपीस
चेंज करना चाहता हूं जैसे की मैं क्या
कहना चाहता हूं कैट कर रहा हूं कैट नहीं
मैं तेल कर रहा हूं तेल क्या मैंने
आईफोन 5 और उसके बाद मैं का रहा हूं स्लैश
पीसी और पास डी पावर डी इंटर किया और जो
मैंने चीन तू है इसका प्राइमरी ग्रुप कौन
सा है ये आईडी इसकी 1055 अब मैं क्या कहना
चाहता हूं इसका प्राइमरी ग्रुप ही चेंज
करना चाहता हूं अगर मैं इसका प्राइमरी
ग्रुप चेंज करना चाहता हूं उसके लिए कमांड
होगी यूजर मोड
आईफोन उसे नहीं करूंगा स्मॉल जी उसे
करूंगा प्राइमरी ग्रुप चेंज करने के लिए
उसके बाद यूनिक्स और उसका ग्रुप का नाम
देखते हैं तो इसका भी जो प्राइमरी ग्रुप
होगा वो चेंज हो गया होगा देखो ये 105106
आएगा अगर मैं उधर देखना चाहूं तो
ग्रुप करके देख सकते हैं
वह चेंज होगी अगर मैं क्या करता हूं आपका
यूनिक्स और सेकेंडरी ग्रुप सी है सेकेंडरी
ग्रुप सी इसका यूनिसिटी
तो यह है अगर इसका प्राइमरी ग्रुप चेंज कर
देते हो लेकिन एक चीज बताता हूं आपको अगर
आपको ग्रुप में मोडिफिकेशन करना है ग्रुप
में पर एग्जांपल मुझे ग्रुप का नाम चेंज
करना है वो मैं कैसे करूंगा उसके लिए होता
है मुझे गो अप ग्रुप मोड उसके बाद आईफोन
एन मतलब मैं उसका नया नाम देना चाहता हूं
ग्रुप का और जैसे नया नाम में यूनिसेफ में
क्या देना चाहता हूं
यूनिक्स देना चाहता हूं और किस ग्रुप का
नाम यू एन आई एक्स का
जो नया नाम आपको देखने को मिलेगा वह रहेगा
आपको तेल
अब उसका नाम चेंज हो गई है
इसका नाम चेंज हो गया इस तरीके से आप क्या
कर सकते हो किसी भी ग्रुप की नोटिफिकेशन
भी कर सकते हो अगर
ग्रुप मोड आईफोन हेल्प करके दिखाऊं तो
सिंपली तो यह सारे ऑप्शन जिसके साथ आप उसे
कर सकते हो जो मैंने उसे किया था न्यू
मतलब न्यू ग्रुप नाम यह आपको पता है अगर
आपको किसी भी ग्रुप को डिलीट करना है वह
कैसे करोगे तो जी आर ओ यू ल कमांड होती है
उसके बाद जैसे ग्रुप का नाम यूनिक्स इंटर
अब इसने क्या बोला की ग्रुप को रिमूव नहीं
कर सकता है क्यों क्योंकि एक चीज ध्यान
रखना जब भी आप किसी भी ग्रुप को डिलीट
करोगे तो वह ग्रुप किसी भी यूजर का
प्राइमरी ग्रुप नहीं होना चाहिए
अगर वह किसी भी यूजर का प्राइमरी ग्रुप
होगा तो उसे ग्रुप को अब डिलीट नहीं कर
सकते पहले आपको क्या करना उसका प्राइमरी
ग्रुप चेंज करना होगा तो मैं कैसे करूंगा
ओके सचिन तू उसके बाद
चेंज कर दिया अब मैं अगर डिलीट करना चाहता
हूं
सॉरी
ब्रो
अब ये क्या है ये आपका ग्रुप डिलीट भी
होगा यूनिक 5.2 क्योंकि ये उसका प्राइमरी
मेंबर अब नहीं है अब यहां पे यूनिक्स नाम
का आपका जो ग्रुप से आपको देखने को नहीं
मिलेगा इस तरीके से आप किसी भी यूजर को
क्या कर सकते हो
डिलीट कर सकते हो लेकिन जो चीज आपको ध्यान
में रखती है वो है की वो उसका प्राइमरी
ग्रुप नहीं होना चाहिए एडरवाइज आपको भी
ग्रुप को क्या नहीं कर पाओगे डिलीट नहीं
कर पाओगे तो यह था हमारा किसी यूजर को
कैसे एड करना है किसी ग्रुप को कैसे एड
करना है किसी भी ग्रुप को कैसे डिलीट करना
है किसी भी वीडियो को कैसे डिलीट करना है
किसी भी उधर को उसके दूसरे सेकेंडरी ग्रुप
का पार्ट कैसे मेंबर बनाना है या किसी भी
यूजर का प्राइमरी ग्रुप कैसे चेंज करना है
और अगर आप ग्रुप डिलीट करते थे क्या
प्रॉब्लम आपके सामने आई है वो आप कैसे कर
सकते हैं किसी भी ग्रुप को मॉडिफाई कैसे
करना है या किसी यूजर को मॉडिफाई कैसे
करना है ये चार-पांच कमांडी थी जो आपको
मैंने बता दिया दूसरा अगर यूजर कोड अब
डिलीट कर रहे हो तो हाइपर आर का आपको
स्पेशली ध्यान रखना है और ध्यान रखते हुए
आपको चीज ये भी ध्यान रखना की क्या आपके
लिए वो सेंसेटिव इनफॉरमेशन है या नहीं अगर
उसके अंदर आपके लिए सेंसेटिव इनफॉरमेशन है
तो पहले उसे इनफॉरमेशन को ट्रांसफर कर
लीजिए एडरवाइज बोलोगे हमें तो सिखाया और
डायरेक्टली आईफोन आरोपियन किया उसके लिए
अंदर से सेंड शेड्यूल्ड डाटा आपका डिलीट
हो गया ये साड़ी चीज आज आपकी क्लास में
कुछ सीखने को मिला होगा आई होप सबको
क्लियर हुआ सबको समझ में ए गया होगा ओके
क्योंकि कुछ भी कन्ज्यूरिंग नहीं था बहुत
ही स्ट्रेट और फॉरवर्ड था अगर फिर भी कुछ
समझ में नहीं आता तो आप के लिए 5 मिनट है
अभी तो 5 मिनट पर डाउट सेशन तो आप पूछ
सकते हो अभी ओपन
वही अगेन आप लोगों को लगता की मैं आपको
अच्छा पढ़ा रहा हूं और आप लोगों के लिए
वैल्युएबल इनफॉरमेशन दो प्लीज प्लीज इट्स
मी रिक्वेस्ट हंबल रिक्वेस्ट अगर आप लोगों
को मुझे अच्छा अच्छा कंटेंट चाहिए और
अच्छा अच्छा आप लोगों मुझे पढ़ना है तो आप
लोग क्या है की इसको शेर करना होगा मैक्स
लोगों तक पहुंचाना चाहिए जिनको इनकी जरूर
है खास दिन के बाद बिल्कुल भी पैसे नहीं
है जस्ट फोन से कम चला रहे हैं बिल्कुल भी
बिल्कुल भी लोग कैटिगरी में जिनको लगता है
की नहीं कर पाएंगे तो प्लीज प्लीज आज के
टाइम में सबके पास इंटरनेट है प्लीज इट्स
मी रिक्वेस्ट पर्सनल नंबर रिक्वेस्ट
क्योंकि मेरा जो
विजन है जो मेरा मिशन है मेरा मिशन है की
उन लोगों तक पहुंचाना जिनको सच में मेरी
जरूर है इनको मैं दिल से हेल्प करना चाहता
हूं क्योंकि उन लोगों की तो हेल्प हो
जाएगी वो कहानी से भी हेल्प कर लेंगे
जिनको कुछ आता है या कहानी ना कहानी जिनके
पास कुछ बैकअप का कुछ कर सकते हैं बट उन
लोगों का क्या जो बिल्कुल ही बिल्कुल का
सकते हैं की
का सकते हैं की जिनके पास कुछ भी नहीं है
कुछ भी सोर्सेस नहीं है और हम उनकी हेल्प
करने के लिए सोच रहे हैं तो प्लीज हमारी
सोच आई है देखो आप लोग जितना स्प्रेड
करोगे जितना आप लोगों को बताओगे जितना आप
सबको बताओगे इस से हमारे बड़े में लोग
जानेंगे इस से आप ही लोग हमारे लिए
क्योंकि हमें आपको पटाया है आप लोग दूसरों
को बताओ प्लीज देखिए अच्छी चीज है और गाइड
चीज क्योंकि मैं आपको एक चीज बताता हूं की
जब हम फरदर क्लासेस और भी कराएंगे किसी और
से टॉपिक पे तो बार-बार इस चीज को कंपेयर
किया जाए क्योंकि मैं फंडामेंटल इसलिए
आपका बनाया है लीडर्स का क्योंकि अभी आपको
हर चीज में इसकी जरूर पढ़ने वाली है और
अगर आपने अभी इसको उसे ढंग से नहीं शिखा
मैं बता रहा हूं की अगर पेन टेस्टिंग भी
करोगे तो आपको बार-बार इधर आने की जरूर
पड़ेगी सीखना पड़ेगा मैंने लो देखा मेरे
साथ जो कम किया चलो जिनको फंडामेंटल कर
लिया
जैसे अटैक होते हैं तो समझ में आई है चीज़
होती क्या है
क्या इस फाइल में ये चीज होती है ये होती
है ये साड़ी चीज रहती है तो वो चीज हमें
पता है तो दास वाई प्लीज सिंपल रिक्वेस्ट
तो आप लोग नेक्स्ट ट्री करो की ज्यादा से
ज्यादा लोगों तक पहुंचे क्या है ब्रीफ्लाई
एक बार ग्रुप को एक्सप्लेन दे दे दीजिए
थोड़ा सा दिखेगा ब्रो की जरूर क्यों पड़ी
देखो क्या होता है की अगर एक कंपनी में
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन में 1000 लोग कम कर रहे हैं
₹1000 लोग कम कर रहे हैं जिम से किसी
प्रोजेक्ट पे 50 लोग कम कर रहे हैं और वो
प्रोजेक्ट क्या है की आप मशीन पे नेक्स्ट
उसे हो रही है और वहां पर क्या है की उसे
प्रोजेक्ट में कम करने के लिए 30 से 40
फाइलें ऐसी है जो उनके ऊपर उनको एक्सेस
होना चाहिए उनको कम करना है वह क्या है
बट क्या है 40 से 50 लोग हैं जो अलग-अलग
सभी को चाहिए
तो क्या आप लोग ही बताइए क्या मैं उन 50
लोगों को उन 35 साल 15 से 20 या जो 35
फाइलें हैं उनके लिए अलग-अलग एक्सेस
डिफाइन करूंगा हर बार उसे यूजर के लिए उसे
फाइल में परमिशन दूंगा इजिप्ट पॉसिबल इन
रियल सिनेरियो नोट पॉसिबल क्योंकि ऐसा
करना इसलिए पॉसिबली एक तो आप उन सबको
मॉनिटर नहीं कर पाओगे कौन क्या कर रहा है
दूसरा क्या है की टाइम गंजूमिंग है इतना
टाइम किसी के पास नहीं है तो उसका एक
सॉल्यूशन निकाला गया क्यों ना हम एक कम
करते हैं 50 लोगों का ग्रुप बनाते हैं और
उसे गुरु उसे ग्रुप को क्या करते हैं कुछ
पेट को परमिशन दे देंगे पांच लोग उसे
ग्रुप का मेंबर बना देंगे और जो फाइल्स
होगी
34 35
34 35 जैसे की कुछ फाइल होंगे जो उसे
प्रोजेक्ट में कम करने के लिए उन फाइलों
पर जो परमिशन चाहिए पर्टिकुलर 50 मेंबर को
उन फाइलों का जो ग्रुप है वह ग्रुप बना
लेंगे जो 50 लोगों का जो ग्रुप है ना वो
हम क्या किसी फाइल का ग्रुप भी चेंज कर
सकते हैं फाइल के जो ओनरशिप है जिसका जो
ग्रुप है वो भी हम चेंज कर सकते हैं रूट
और जो रूट रूट देखने को मिलता है तो उसको
हम चेंज कर सकते हैं हम क्या करेंगे हम
प्रकाश फाइलों का ग्रुप चेंज कर देंगे और
उसे ग्रुप का नाम दाल देंगे जी पर जिनको
उसके परमिशन देनी है इसलिए उससे क्या होगा
एक सिक्योरिटी मेंटेन रहेगी 50 लोग अंदर
मॉनिटर रहेंगे और आपको 25 से 35 फाइलों के
ऊपर हर बार किसी के परमिशन देनी पड़ेगी
अगर कोई 51 से 52 वाले इंसान भी आता है
तब सिंपली क्या करोगे उसको कम मेंबर बना
डॉग कल को आपको लगता है की नहीं ये एक
मेंबर हमारे पास नहीं रहना चाहिए हम इसको
आउट करना तो सिंपली आउट कर डॉग ना की आप
फाइल पे हर एक इंडिविजुअल के एक्सेस को
लिमिट करोगे जी दिन रीजन तू मेक डी ग्रुप
आई हो की ओझा जी आपको क्लियर हो गया होगा
क्या ग्रुप अभी भी क्लियर नहीं हुआ
बताइए प्लीज चाट बताइए